A estas alturas creo que todos, absolutamente
todos estáis familiarizados con noticias
como esta, [aunque solo sea porque hemos hablado
de ello hace muy poquito tiempo en VisualPolitik]
(La UE pide a los países recortar la demanda
de gas un 15% hasta la primavera - Reuters)
La cruel e injustificada invasión rusa de
Ucrania y las consiguientes sanciones internacionales
han puesto a los países de la Unión Europea
justo en la diana de Vladimir Putin.
Y eso es algo que en cierta forma resulta
algo aterrador: no olvidéis que en países
como la República Checa, Austria, Alemania
o Eslovaquia, no es extraño que la temperatura
alcance los 15 grados bajo cero.
Así que pasar un invierno sin calefacción
es casi un reto imposible de cumplir.
El problema, tal y como podéis ver en este
mapa, es que muchos países europeos se han
vuelto terriblemente dependientes del gas
ruso.
Y de todos ellos un caso que llama especialmente
la atención por su enorme consumo y por lo
importante que resulta su economía para toda
la Unión Europea - empezando por que es con
mucha diferencia el mayor contribuyente del
club comunitario - es precisamente el de Alemania.
(Durante la primera mitad del 2022, y a pesar
de la Guerra de Ucrania, la dependencia alemana
del gas ruso se situó en torno al 40%.
Esto hace que un posible corte de gas por
parte de Moscú se perciba como toda una pesadilla,
tanto en lo económico como en lo social.
Un corte del gas podría suponer que muchas
fábricas tuvieran que cerrar y que las calefacciones
dejaran de funcionar mientras el invierno
conduce las temperaturas a varios grados bajo
cero)
Para colmo, las reservas de gas alemanas se
encuentran muy tensionadas, y en el momento
de preparar este vídeo se estima que como
mucho podrían satisfacer la demanda durante
unos dos meses y medio.
Algo claramente insuficiente para resistir
todo el invierno.
(24 de junio de 2022 - El regulador energético
de Alemania dice que el país puede soportar
dos meses y medio sin gas ruso, y que habrá
un otoño y un invierno “difícil” por
delante - Fortune)
De hecho, tras el corte del Nord Stream por
“mantenimiento” durante 10 días, Alemania
se vio obligada a tirar en pleno verano de
sus reservas para el invierno.
Lo que, como os podéis imaginar, no ha contribuido
precisamente a que el país se prepare para
la llegada del frío.
(El corte de gas de Rusia está obligando
al mayor comprador de Europa de su suministro
a reducir las reservas de emergencia de invierno.
La empresa ha tenido que apoyarse en sus suministros
de emergencia de invierno para cumplir con
las obligaciones contractuales con sus clientes
- Markets Insider)
Ahora bien, todo esto de la enorme dependencia
que Alemania tiene del gas ruso es algo que
todos sabemos.
Hasta aquí nada nuevo.
La pregunta es, ¿Hasta dónde llega realmente
la adicción alemana al gas ruso?
¿Cómo demonios se llegó a está situación?
¿Por qué Alemania se expuso tanto a los
suministros de un país como Rusia?
¿Es que nadie vio el gigantesco riesgo político
que esto conllevaba?
Pues…
Queridos amigos, amigas, lo cierto es que
la cosa viene de lejos y que no existe un
único responsable.
Ni siquiera el propio ex-canciller Gerhard
Schröder, que terminó siendo colocado por
Putin como ejecutivo de Gazprom cobrando una
millonada y que, por supuesto, ahora se ha
convertido en radiactivo.
Nadie quiere tener lazos con él.
Pero, un momento, porque en este vídeo no
solo vamos a ver quienes son los culpables
de esta enorme debilidad de Alemania, sino
que también vamos a intentar entender cuál
es la situación exacta en la que se encuentra
Alemania y lo que esto puede conllevar.
Así pues, ¿Cómo diantres los alemanes no
tuvieron en cuenta la seguridad de suministro
y el riesgo político a la hora de diseñar
su sistema energético?
¿Quién o quiénes son los responsables de
todo este gigantesco desaguisado?
Y lo que puede resultar aún mucho más importante
de cara al futuro: ¿Qué puede ocurrir si
finalmente se interrumpe el suministro de
gas ruso a la mayor potencia europea?
Pues bien, veámoslo.
T1 (MI AMIGO RUSO)
Las relaciones entre los alemanes y los rusos,
sobre todo en lo que respecta a la cuestión
energética, no son, precisamente, nuevas.
El día 1 de febrero de 1970 altos cargos
políticos y responsables del sector gasístico
de Alemania wy de la por aquel entonces Unión
Soviética firmaron la construcción del primer
gasoducto entre los yacimientos de Siberia
y los consumidores de la República Federal
Alemana.
Si, sí, lo habéis escuchado bien.
Ni siquiera el telón de acero, la impermeable
y gélida barrera que dominó la guerra fria,
evitó que el gas ruso comenzará a fluir
desde los campos de extracción soviéticos
hasta occidente.
(Y no solo se trata de que el gas comenzara
a fluir entre países antagónicos, sino que
ni siquiera las fuertes tensiones de la Guerra
Fria lograron poner en peligro el suministro.
De esta forma, poco a poco, con el paso de
las décadas, esta seguridad permite, ladrillo
a ladrillo, desarrollar fuertes lazos de confianza
y amistad comercial entre los alemanes y los
rusos.
Unos lazos que han llegado…
Hasta ahora y que tuvieron su punto de partida
con la llamada Ostpolitik, un proceso de normalización
de las relaciones entre Alemania Occidental
y el bloque del este impulsado por el ex-Canciller
Willy Brandt.)
Ahora bien, si estos lazos perduraron en el
tiempo es porque durante prácticamente 50
años estás relaciones ruso-germanas conllevaron
muchos beneficios para las dos partes.
Sin ir más lejos, Alemania estuvo durante
décadas aprovechándose de un suministro
abundante y muy barato de gas con el que,
por ejemplo, alimentó su avanzada industria
pesada.
Una industria que se colocó en una posición
muy competitiva tanto a nivel europeo como
mundial.
Eso es precisamente lo que explica que el
consumo alemán de gas ruso no dejara de crecer…
hasta el año 2021.
A cambio Rusia no sólo recibió una inmensa
cantidad de dólares sino que Alemania también
trató a Rusia como un socio prioritario y
le vendió todo tipo de bienes industriales
y tecnología avanzada.
Era por así decirlo un win-win muy claro.
Ahora bien, volvamos a la pregunta que hemos
hecho antes: ¿por qué Alemania Occidental
tomó la decisión de echarse en brazos de
la Unión Soviética y el bloque del este
para resolver sus necesidades energéticas?
Pues bien, en aquella época los políticos
alemanas estaban convencidos - y la historia
demuestra que no estaban tan equivocados - que
promover el comercio con el bloque del este
era la mejor forma de mejorar la estabilidad
política en Europa.
Cuanto más comercio, mejor que mejor.
Y desde luego, no seremos nosotros quienes
intenten refutar esa idea.
El problema es que el comercio de energía
no es como comprar y vender coches o zapatillas.
La energía es la base del sistema productivo
y económico.
Y por eso garantizar el suministro de energía,
incluso aunque esto pueda conllevar mayores
costes resulta fundamental.
Sin embargo, la idea de que algo pudiera detener
el suministro, ni siquiera se pasó por la
cabeza de los políticos alemanes hasta hace
prácticamente cuatro días.
(“Una interrupción de largo plazo [del
suministro energético] iría en contra de
los propios intereses de la Unión Soviética.”
- Informe de ministerios alemanes, finales
de la década de 1980)
(“Los que comercian entre sí no se disparan
unos a otros.”
- Helmut Schmidt, ex-Canciller de Alemania
Occidental, a Jimmy Carter)
(“Hablar de dependencia económica de Moscú
por parte de la República Federal en un grado
lo suficientemente grande como para afectar
a la política exterior indica ignorancia
o malicia”.
- Helmut Schmidt, en 1980)
Y de esta forma, hasta el año 2021, Alemania
desarrolló una dependencia salvaje hacia
Rusia.
Para ese año, ni más ni menos que el 55%
de todo su consumo de gas procedía de las
tierras de Pedro el Grande.
La percepción era que cuánto más gas ruso
barato entrara en Alemania, mejor que mejor.
Así que, por ejemplo, cuando la producción
de gas alemana comenzó a menguar por el agotamiento
de algunos yacimientos y las presiones de
grupos ecologistas, ¿sabéis lo que hicieron
los alemanes?
3,2,1….
Exacto, pedirle más gas a los rusos.
Ni siquiera tras la invasión y posterior
anexión de Crimea los políticos alemanes
tomaron medidas para diversificar sus fuentes
de energía.
Y de hecho fue todo lo contrario, fijaos:
30 de mayo de 2011: Alemania cerrará todos
los reactores nucleares.
La medida está motivada por las protestas
masivas contra la energía nuclear tras el
desastre nuclear de Japón.
The Guardian)
Pero, claro, ¿a quién le importaba?
Mientras los políticos alemanes pudieran
vender éxitos económicos y energía barata,
¿por qué preocuparse por Rusia?
¿Para qué perder el tiempo pensando en cosas
como la seguridad energética?
Y más aún si podían hacer negocio.
Este fue el caso del ex canciller de Alemania
Gerhard Schröder.
Quien dirigió el timón de Alemania entre
los años 1998 y 2005, no solo se jacta hasta
de ser colega de Putin y visitarlo frecuentemente
sino que también trabajó para proyectos
vinculados con el gobierno ruso que él mismo
había promovido.
Este fue el caso, por ejemplo, de Nord Stream,
una empresa controlada por Rusia que fue la
encargada de construir el primer gasoducto
submarino que conecta Rusia con Alemania.
El propio Putin le instó a convertirse en
el presidente del Comité de Accionistas.
De esta forma a cambio de un generoso salario
Schröder se encargó de promover las bondades
del gas ruso por toda Alemania.
Y no fue su única dedicación.
Desde el año 2017 Schröder también formó
parte de la Junta Directiva de la petrolera
rusa Rosneft.
¿La recompensa por este sillón?
Otros 600 mil dólares anuales.
("Se aprovechó de la reputación e influencia
de la cancillería y se ofreció como agente
de los intereses rusos para enriquecerse".
Norbert Röttgen, parlamentario conservador
y ex ministro)
Por supuesto no fue un caso aislado.
Muchos políticos alemanes, directa o indirectamente,
participaron de este enorme negocio hasta
que el globo estalló.
Su excusa es que Rusia nunca cortaría el
suministro de gas porque no le interesa asumir
una pérdida económica tan grande.
El problema es que hoy sabemos que no todo
el mundo se comporta de una forma tan eficiente
como los rígidos políticos alemanes.
Si una vez más algo nos ha enseñado Vladimir
Putin es que en ocasiones la opción más
racional no es la opción escogida.
En otras circunstancias nunca habría tenido
lugar la irracional invasión de Ucrania.
Así que teniendo esto presente la pregunta
es, ¿hasta dónde llega el problema de Alemania?
Pues bien, veámoslo.
T2 (EL JUEGO QUE EMPIEZA PERDIDO)
Pese a todos los esfuerzos que se han realizado
para reducirla, la dependencia alemana del
gas ruso sigue siendo de entorno al 40% de
todo su consumo de gas.
Y si eso ya es preocupante hay numerosos que
son incluso peores.
(“La situación se volverá aún peor si
las importaciones o los suministros de gas
y petróleo rusos se detienen.
[...] Una recesión significativa en Alemania
sería entonces virtualmente inevitable.”
- Christian Sewing, CEO de Deutsche Bank)
Y amigos, estas palabras pueden quedarse cortas.
Me explico, esto que veis en pantalla es la
forma en la que se reparte el consumo de gas
en Alemania.
Como veis, el mayor consumidor de gas alemán
es la industria, en particular la industria
pesada que es terriblemente intensiva en energía.
En total se traga casi el 40% del consumo
total.
Luego están los hogares, que son responsables
de algo más del 30% del consumo de gas con
el cuál se abastecen de calefacción, agua
caliente y energía para cocinar, principalmente.
Y luego entre el 9 y el 15% de todo el gas
consumido se destina a la producción eléctrica.
Así que según las estimaciones de diversas
instituciones, si Rusia cortara completamente
el suministro de gas, además de pasar frío,
los alemanes se enfrentarían a una importante
recesión económica.
Y como los alemanes, los políticos alemanes
quiero decir, le tienen auténtico pavor a
las crisis, ahora podéis entender por qué
han forzado a la Comisión Europea a imponer
un plan para reducir el consumo de gas en
toda Europa.
Claro que, un momento, porque no todo es culpa
de Rusia.
La propia Alemania ha sido un complice necesario
para llegar a esta situación.
Y no hablamos sólo del dinero ruso.
Con la llamada “transición energética”
Alemania ha cerrado 14 de sus 17 reactores
nucleares….
En principio con la idea de sustituirlos por
energías limpias.
El problema es que las renovables más habituales,
la energía eólica y la solar no tienen,
como todos sabéis, una producción regular,
así que necesitan una tercera fuente de energía
que actúe como respaldo.
Y la política alemana ha hecho que esas centrales
sean precisamente las de gas.
Pero eso no es todo.
Alemania también tiene mucho más difícil
sustituir el gas ruso que otros países europeos.
¿Por qué?
Pues porque no tiene infraestructuras alternativas.
Como el gas ruso llegaba a raudales por los
gasoductos, Alemania nunca apostó por construir
regasificadoras con las que poder importar
gas natural licuado.
El GNL, para los que no lo sepáis, es la
forma en la que el gas se transporta en estado
líquido a bordo de grandes metaneros, con
lo cual al llegar a puerto necesita de unidades
de regasificación para devolverlo de forma
segura a su estado gaseoso.
Es decir, no solo hablamos de que los alemanes
no buscaran fuentes alternativas y no se preocuparan
de su dependencia del gas ruso, es que ni
siquiera construyeron una infraestructura
alternativa por si acaso, tal y como sí hicieron
otros países.
Por ejemplo, hace aproximadamente una década
Lituania invirtió en una terminal flotante
para almacenar y regasificar el gas natural
licuado.
Se llama Independencia y se encuentra anclada
en el puerto de Klaipeda.
Pues bien, esta planta le ha permitido a Lituania
convertirse en el primer país europeo en
dejar de comprarle gas a Rusia.
Sea como sea, la cuestión es que Alemania
tiene por delante un escenario bastante complicado.
Y eso explica que de cara al invierno se hayan
puesto manos a la obra para reducir el consumo
de gas.
Por ejemplo, están reactivando sus viejas
centrales eléctricas de carbón.
Y justo aquí aparece también la cuestión
nuclear.
Tras el accidente de Fukushima Merkel decidió
cerrar todas las plantas nucleares de Alemania.
Una postura que se ha convertido en toda una
política de estado que, sin embargo, ahora
se está agrietando.
El debate vuelve a estar sobre la mesa.
(“Si reactivamos las tres plantas que fueron
apagadas el pasado diciembre podrían, junto
a las tres que aún operan, reemplazar todo
el carbón que importamos de Rusia o el 30%
del gas ruso.”
- Marc Bernhard, miembro del Parlamento alemán
por AfD)
Las reticencias para hacerlo no son técnicas
sino políticas.
Y en estos momentos proceden sobre todo de
una parte muy concreta de la coalición de
gobierno.
(“Sería un suicidio para Los Verdes decir
que estábamos equivocados sobre la energía
nuclear.
[...] Así que se ven obligados a continuar
con el viejo plan de batalla.”
- Thomas O’Donnell, analista de energía
y físico nuclear basado en Alemania)
Pese a todo, no hay muchas más alternativas,
así que como mínimo es casi seguro que el
cierre programado de los 3 reactores que quedan
operativos que está previsto para finales
del 2022 se retrasará de forma indefinida.
das las plantas nucleares de Alemania.
Una postura que se ha convertido en toda una
política de estado que, sin embargo, ahora
se está agrietando.
El debate vuelve a estar sobre la mesa.
C6 (“If we reactivate the three plants that
were switched off last December they could,
together with the three that are still operating,
replace all the coal we import from Russia
or 30 per cent of the Russian gas.”
- Marc Bernhard, member of the german Parliament
for AfD)
(“Si reactivamos las tres plantas que fueron
apagadas el pasado diciembre podrían, junto
a las tres que aún operan, reemplazar todo
el carbón que importamos de Rusia o el 30%
del gas ruso.”
- Marc Bernhard, miembro del Parlamento alemán
por AfD)
Las reticencias para hacerlo no son técnicas
sino políticas.
Y en estos momentos proceden sobre todo de
una parte muy concreta de la coalición de
gobierno.
C7 (“It would be suicide for the Greens
to say we were wrong about nuclear power.
[...] So they’re forced to continue with
the old battle plan.”
- Thomas O’Donnell, a Germany-based energy
analyst and nuclear physicist)
(“Sería un suicidio para Los Verdes decir
que estábamos equivocados sobre la energía
nuclear.
[...] Así que se ven obligados a continuar
con el viejo plan de batalla.”
- Thomas O’Donnell, analista de energía
y físico nuclear basado en Alemania)
Pese a todo, no hay muchas más alternativas,
así que como mínimo es casi seguro que el
cierre programado de los 3 reactores que quedan
operativos que está previsto para finales
del 2022 se retrasará de forma indefinida.
N5 (Scholz Opens Door for Extending Nuclear
Power in Germany - Bloomberg)
(3 de agosto de 2022: Scholz dice que “puede
tener sentido” mantener funcionando las
centrales nucleares de Alemania - Le Monde)
En fin, así están las cosas por el corazón
de la vieja Europa.
Pero llegados hasta aquí, turno para ti:
¿Crees que Rusia le terminará cortando todo
el suministro de gas a Alemania?
¿Se verá obligada Europa a tener que racionar
el gas?
Y lo que resulta aún mucho más importante
a largo plazo:
¿Habrán aprendido de una vez por todas los
alemanes lo importante que resulta garantizar
la seguridad energética?
Déjanos tu opinión aquí debajo, en los
comentarios.
Y, si te ha resultado interesante este vídeo,
no te olvides de darle a like y suscribirte
a nuestro canal dándole también a la campanita
para no perderte ninguna novedad.
Además, si te gusta nuestro trabajo, puedes
ayudarnos a mejorar y a crecer uniéndote
a nuestra comunidad en Patreon.
Tenéis el enlace en la descripción.
Dicho esto, muchas gracias por estar ahí.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima